the og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
fan show i am very excited for this
conversation today we have so much to
get through um obviously we're talking
all about bitcoin now before i kick this
show off i do want to say a massive
thank you to our sponsors bitmex because
as always without them we want to be
able to bring you such important content
so a quick message from bitmex before we
bring our guest on so bit mex is the og
crypto derivatives exchange and now has
a spot exchange for you to buy and sell
your crypto especially in a bear market
you need a name that you can trust and
bitmex sets the standard for reliability
performance and transparency it is
proven itself through multiple multiple
market cycles and that is very important
because it has stood the test of time
we're seeing a lot of uh companies right
now go under so you need a company that
you can trust right now bitmex is
actually celebrating the start of bitmex
spot with one million dollars in usd as
a prize so all you have to do to enter
um users just need to trade uh the
crypto equivalent of 250 us dollars
which means you know you could purchase
some bitcoin um
you could purchase around 250 in bitcoin
now seems like a great time um and yeah
you can actually enter up to 25 times um
to win um and one lucky winner could
actually get 500 000 us dollars in
bitcoin so i'm gonna leave all the
information for you in the description
below if you are watching on youtube
then you'll just see it all in the
description below bimx is a great place
so a huge thank you to them especially
because we talk about a lot of
controversial things on the show um and
that's what we're gonna get into now
before i bring on my guest please if you
are watching on youtube don't forget to
hit the subscribe button so you never
miss a video and also hit the like
button so you can support this channel
alright guys let's do this so joining me
today is the co-founder of looking glass
it is greg foss greg welcome to the show
how are you
what a great time to be here thank you
so much for having me
yeah it's great to see you uh we met a
couple of weeks ago um at the conference
so
before you know we delve into this for
those who don't know you can you just
give us your background
certainly um yeah it was great to meet
you at bitcoin miami um
i am a 35-year veteran of credit trading
i earned my stripes in the junk bond
market
starting on the sell side of the street
i worked for a canadian broker dealer
and then i moved to the hedge fund
community
and lived the great financial crisis in
the hedge fund community
i've experienced four substantial
financial crises in my life
started with the latin american debt
crisis in 1988 and it
second crisis was long-term capital
management the third crisis was the
great financial crisis 2008
and then the kobe crisis so i think i
have some
you know let's call them work war scars
and i i
what i bring to the table i'd like to
say is 35 years of mistakes but i'm
still alive i'm fighting the good fight
because
you got to learn how to manage your risk
and that's what i like to think i am i'm
a uh i'm a credit risk manager or a risk
manager
i'm so excited to speak to you four uh
four crises i can't even say that word
uh full crisis season it's gonna be
pretty crazy um you know the kobe crisis
2008 and everything else that you
mentioned um but before you know we
delve into this i am interested to know
how you first got into bitcoin
well it's sort of a neat you know it was
a long process so i'm a canadian
but i
completed two years of university in the
united states i got my mba
at an ivy league school called cornell
university and while i had the chance to
work on wall street i decided i wanted
to come back to canada and i ended up
working for canada's largest financial
institution in 1988 and i was working
directly for the cfo
it was a special projects group and i
like to think of myself as an engineer a
financial engineer but i did train in
undergrad as an engineer
so i was in a restructuring in
the royal bank of canada and one of my
projects the first projects was working
on the latin american debt restructuring
royal bank of canada was very similar to
other global banks they had lent way too
much money to lesser developed countries
lbc countries of which south america
made up a huge component of that
and in 1988
u.s treasury secretary nicholas brady
proposed a plan to the global banking
system to restructure the debt of mexico
it was the first plan that turned out to
be the first of many
and i was assigned the task of
evaluating the brady plan options and
you know i did a quick back in the
envelope mathematical calculation
and i realized that the world bank of
canada was technically insolvent which
is to say
the book value of equity of the royal
bank of canada was vaporized if the
latin american debt portfolio was marked
to market
now you'd think that the financial
analysts on wall street bay street would
have figured this out pretty quickly but
they didn't
so you know i go in to see the cfo
his name was emil great guy
and ago emil we have a problem
and he said i know don't tell anybody
now
as the largest financial institution in
canada
this was mind-blowing to me firstly that
the analysts didn't understand what was
going on secondly every equity
shareholder of royal bank of canada
certainly had no idea what was going on
and most importantly
i wasn't allowed to tell anybody now not
that i would have because you know i'm a
25 year old kid what do i do run out to
the wall street journal and tell them
that the global banking system is
insolvent clearly there was a problem
because that's why treasury secretary
nicholas brady
proposed the restructuring plan the
point is over a 25-year period
of dealing with these restructurings
i have been exposed to what i call the
fiat ponzi
okay now the fiat haunts you
before you explain the fiat ponzi are
you able just to speak a bit closer into
your mic because the background noise is
coming through quite loud um
and i don't want people to miss this
okay so i am in an airport so i
apologize so they think you're doing the
dishes greg they think you're doing the
dishes that's what i'm getting in the
comments come a little bit closer okay
is that better now
a little bit um
oh it's better when you come closer when
you come closer you know what i might be
on the wrong mic then i think i'm on the
wrong mic uh it should be going through
my headphones give me one second no
okay
no worries all right we're gonna get
greg's mic
this is settings okay no worries
all right so we're going to get greg's
mic switch and then we're going to find
out about the fiat ponzi
um which i think is pretty important
actually because a lot of people right
now um giving bitcoins prices down are
talking a lot about how bitcoin is a
ponzi scheme um which obviously we know
isn't true um but they they fail to hear
how the fiat system is a ponzi scheme so
i'm really excited to get into this
are you able to switch it
is that better no
can you count to 10 for us
10 9
8
7.
it's okay i can just we can just still
hear you but if you just speak louder
then hopefully you can overcome it
okay give me one more sec
all right i'm gonna try one more
guys this is what happens when you do it
live
this is this is
is that oh that's better
yes let's go with that okay let's go
with that okay so yeah keep it close if
you can okay so basically
the
the problem with the fiat ponzi starts
with the commercial banking system
and the reason that's a problem is
because commercial banks are 25 times
levered
to their capital base which is to say
that for every hundred dollars of loans
a bank makes
only four to six dollars is equity
capital or risk absorbing capital and
the other 94 to 96 dollars
is
your depositor's money or subordinated
debt so how often do you think
a bank makes a loan
and the value of that loan depo declines
by more than six dollars well it happens
all the time okay if you've ever traded
debt
which i've done for 35 years you know
that the prices of bonds fall
by far more than six dollars over the
economic cycle whether it's because of
credit risk primarily because of credit
risk or it's because of changing
interest
expectations on behalf of the central
banks globally bond prices are volatile
very simply leia
commercial banks need
inflation in order for their collateral
to increase in value to compensate for
their under
capitalization that is the fiat ponzi in
a nutshell
after 35 years i finally found bitcoin
bitcoin is the only digital asset that
solves the fee of ponzi very simple
the thing which blows my mind is um
the fact that you know from your
perspective you know these people know
that it's a ponzi right like you were
told not to say anything and and by the
way there was nothing coercive there um
you know
it was it was a bit of a you know
tongue-in-cheek yes this is the
commercial banking system but the
reality is henry ford said the same
thing
about a hundred over a hundred years ago
right he quoted he was quoted as saying
if the average american understood how
the commercial banking system works
there'd be a revolution in the morning
so you know it's it's a fact of the
structure of the
fiat system where you have
commercial banks that need to have an
incredible amount of leverage to earn
proper returns for their equity holders
it's just it basically uh puts the
system at risk of
cyclical failure and notice that the
first one 1988 was followed 10 years
later 1998 was followed 10 years later
2008 was followed 10 years later
2020
okay the depths of these crises
get more severe because the central
banks bail out the system and kick the
can down the road
and
consequently we are in a spiral a debt
spiral that can never be repaid
and thus currency debasing is 100
certain
would it be
fair to say that you believe it's
destruction by design
heart i i can't go that far out on the
limb it's
designed this way because it's always
been designed this way until there's an
alternative and that's why i'm so
excited about the parallel building a
parallel network that's built on
uh
different foundations totally and you
mentioned that 10-year cycle and then we
get to obviously covid um in
2020. so that's one of the crisis which
you mentioned how does how is that
comparable to the other previous
financial crisis you know like once
financial ones medical so can you
explain the connection yeah okay for
sure i guess what i should have said it
was a financial crisis in the response
by the central bank so for example what
happened in 2020 that never happened
before was that the federal reserve said
they would buy high-yield bonds okay
that was the first ever in history that
the fed came out and said they would buy
high-yield bonds why did they say that
very simply because there were four
different u.s based credits
they are general electric general motors
ford and a t and t that were on the cusp
of being downgraded from investment
grade a subjective
investment guideline for bondholders
from investment grade to high yield the
combined debt of those four companies is
bigger than the existing high yield
market as a whole so if they had been
downgraded into the high yield market
and caused for selling by the investment
grade sellers that have to sell their
bonds into a high-yield market it would
have overwhelmed the high-yield market
to the extent that it would have caused
a collapse of the equity market because
the equity got the bond guys rank
as a prior claim in the capital
structure well guess what guys like me
do when you own a bunch of general
electric debt
that
is
becoming more credit risky you go out
and you short the common stock so you
see how the cascade effect works through
the system and therefore the 2020
although it was a response as you
mentioned to a medical crisis the
financial crisis was more of the same
uh-oh get involved print money try and
contain the contagion because as high
yield goes so goes equity markets so
what the fed was actually trying to do
was control volatility
by back stopping the high yield market
okay and it worked to an extent it
regained confidence that's all it's
about is the confidence the liquidity of
the system they don't care so much with
the prices as long as it still moves
meaning it trades what really happens in
every crisis is things gum up there's no
trading there's no liquidity things fall
by literally 20 points 20 bond points
which is a 20 drop in the price of a
bond
let me tell you that's not supposed to
happen but bringing it right back to the
banking system
if
if a bond drops by 20 points
the same thing happens with the loan
okay the two things are peripassu
meaning they rank exactly the same in
the credit strike structure for an
investment grade bond if general
electric debt fell by 20 points so did
the bank loan and imagine what happens
with the bank loan that means all the
banks that only have six dollars of
capital
they just lost twenty dollars uh-oh what
does that mean
it means that the financial system
is insolvent again hence the fed
backstop i hope i didn't lose too many
viewers here but you see how how it's
all contained within the leverage
structure of the of the banking system
yeah no i appreciate you um you know
taking the time to explain that no the
viewers are going up it's all good we're
we're good um this is this is valuable
knowledge it's good to know um
so you know what you're talking about um
in my opinion is um very it's a very
specific kind of knowledge that not a
lot of people um you know have
um you know it's it's more than being
financially literate um and so that's
what you do right you educate people you
promote financial literacy yeah well we
tried that yeah when i sat in that risk
chair
there's nothing like learning by
uh trial by fire let's put it that way
you can study all the financial
textbooks you want and they'll talk
about things like efficient market
theory and whatever let me tell you when
the world is melting down there is no
efficient markets there's like get me
out i need to raise money for my unit
holders because i'm being uh margin
called
i need to hit a bid i need to hit some
sort of liquidity bid and so you throw
in a liquidity bid that's like 20 points
below where the last bond traded and
guess what you own them and you're like
oh my god i own these bonds down 20
points that means all the other bonds
that trade in that same industry need to
be marked down in lockstep because the
credit risk of the industry trades as a
contagion type of uh analysis so look
all i will say is sitting in a risk
chair is a very important education and
i did that for 30 years and that's the
biggest problem i have with chairman
powell
he's a he is a lawyer he has never sat
in a risk chair he's never felt
well i have expressions and i won't use
them on your show
you know the tightening of certain body
parts that uh that indicate sitting in a
wrist chair that you know you certainly
don't experience
living in a classroom you need to be in
that chair understanding when the market
stops working and why it's so dangerous
yeah but the but you're the co-founder
of um looking gloss which basically
looks to inspire financial literacy
teach financial literacy right now
that's a free platform and that's
because i wrote an article the genesis
of that was i wrote an article that
basically detailed my 30-year chris
history in the credit markets
and it was submitted to bitcoin magazine
and it was quite well received
and what happened though there were a
lot of
readers that are like oh my god i needed
to open up a google doc to
see what foss was talking about the
whole time because i believe every
single credit manager in the world needs
to own bitcoin as insurance on the
credit portfolio meaning on the fiat
ponzi okay so i wrote those thoughts in
a uh in an article what that's one of
the reasons i got invited to to speak at
the first uh bitcoin miami conference
and it was well received but it was
written and i wrote it on purpose for
portfolio managers credit portfolio
match who were weird bunch okay we're a
bunch of square pegs in a round hole a
lot of times you know
but at the end of the day they said can
you write it in layman's language and i
partnered with the group at looking
glass education to do that we did the
first article again it was quite well
received and we said well why don't we
do this
on a regular basis so really now i'm
very proud to be part of it but i am not
the one running it it's the two young
men one from australia his name is daz
bay
or b
and he's a great kid uh you know younger
than me so he's a kid and then another
one from whistler british columbia who's
a new zealand expat who lives here in
whistler that's where i just got back
from and the two of them are running
this education platform that here's i'm
very proud of it's been translated into
eight different languages and it's being
used in el salvador as the education
platform in el salvador okay so lots of
really good stuff happening we just got
back from madeira for example and
they're gonna translate it into
portuguese and use it in the in the
madeiran
educational system etc so yeah i'm a
co-founder i guess you know but let me
be very clear i don't write specifically
for that anymore but the kids and when i
say kids one one's in his 30s and once
in his 20s they're doing an amazing
amazing job of this and i'm very proud
to you know have been part of that for
sure
well let's talk about financial literacy
because you know they don't talk about
that in schools um you know everything
that you we've just mentioned and i know
you said it was only from experience
that you really understood about this
fiat death spiral um
but
why isn't it taught in schools and also
it's a great question
let me we'll hit that question first
because if they taught you
that the fiat ponzi existed no one would
deposit their money in the commercial
banks would they
they'd be like okay i'm teaching all
these kids through university that they
shouldn't trust the financial system
oh my goodness
that destroys the fiat system itself so
they can't teach you
and the places that we're seeing it
catch on right now are parts of the
world that are non-g7 right it's you
know it's the g7 countries that run the
world they run the education system in
the g7 countries but you're seeing it
actually catch on in the less privileged
countries of the world where reality can
be taught but you can't learn this in
britain all right as soon as they taught
you this in britain your your you know
your your famous bank street would go
out of business okay so you know make
sure that we we know what the incentives
are to teach the truth and by the way i
went through six years of university so
four years of engineering and two years
of finance at in a business school in
the usa and trust me they absolutely
don't teach you this
why well
because it would mean that people would
question the viability and the
sustainability of the current financial
system
so let's bring bitcoin into this how
does bitcoin solve everything that
you've mentioned
in a nutshell from my perspective i
believe bitcoin to be credit insurance
i believe it to be essentially the
equivalent of a credit default swap now
i don't want to get too granular with
your listeners but it's especially
purchasing insurance on a basket
of fiat currencies and i can value that
using credit default swaps on sovereign
nations this is the gist of my thesis
that bitcoin should be thought of as
credit insurance now wall street has not
agreed with that yet they've decided
they're going to trade it like a risk
asset and all the algos in in new york
are going to trade it in correlation to
the s p and the nasdaq but over time as
big money becomes smarter and it takes
time for big money to be smart
most big money is stupid as
a post okay including lots of canadian
pension funds that for example just off
the you know on the topic one large
canadian pension fund that invested in
celsius network seed capital round or
series b before
point
this is the mark a very foolish
asset manager but the reality is they
exist all over the world these types of
asset managers who do traditional things
and don't study things that hard
and they're staffed by you know some old
fat white guys like me and at the end of
the day they are lazy they're
intellectually lazy so
it takes time to
to teach the world new tricks and i
believe it'll happen but right now there
is
i believe that bitcoin should be
inversely correlated to risk markets
meaning as equity markets are tanking
bitcoin should actually have a bigger
bid because it's insurance it's like
fire insurance and right now the fire is
on our back porch
and the price of fire insurance has
actually gone down it's a beautiful
thing
it doesn't make sense but not all
markets make sense
so what is it about bitcoin's properties
that make it insurance
again
it's the anti-fiat okay so it's it is
essentially credit protection on the
default of a company excuse me a country
and that's exactly what it is now you
know there's various risk natures of
countries around the world but
you would agree with me that argentina
defaulting for the fifth time in my
career is not a really good track record
well people who live in argentina should
own insurance against that regular
regularly scheduled event in argentina
people in turkey should feel the same
way but believe it or not there is a
credit default swap market on the united
states of america
which indicates there's people that are
betting on the possibility
of a default of the us treasury now
that is not as high likelihood but it's
not a zero percent likelihood either and
the value of that credit insurance
requires that you have a counterparty
well the beautiful thing about bitcoin
is there's no counterparty risk and
there is no
time decay
bitcoin is actually the perfect
insurance contract
because
you know for example when i lived a
great financial crisis and i was short
for example
owned protection on the default of a
company like lehman brothers now i never
owned lehman but just imagine i owned
protection on lehman
and
i owned it by bear stearns and all of a
sudden bear stearns is going down just
like lehman then i have to run out and
buy protection on bear stearns which was
really my protection on lehman you see
how everything cascades
down and down and down so the beautiful
thing about the coin is an instrument
that in my opinion is the perfect
financial option to protect against
the contagion in global financial
markets including country defaults
it's good saying this and i i do agree
you know on a long-term um sort of like
a macro perspective but right now you
know bitcoins down and you know
inflation is up and you know everything
that could go wrong seems to be going
wrong cost of living everything and
unfortunately you know people and people
look to bitcoin as that hedge against
inflation and apparently you know it
hasn't really performed for them right
now
so what would you say to these people um
you know who say really how can it be
you know this this insurance this hedge
um you know if this is the current state
so again for me it's not a hedge on
inflation as much as a hedge on global
calamity but people use the use that
analogy that it's digital gold and
therefore they think that it has to be
an inflation hedge look what bitcoin is
over the long term will be a
non-quarterly
what's beautiful in financial management
a non-correlated asset and people say
well why is that the case and very
simply there is the uncertainty because
of the global debt spiral that fiat
[Music]
oh i think you've cut out i don't know
if it's me or if it's you can you guys
let me know in the comments um
whether it's me or whether it's greg
that's cut out
dude are we back though
yeah did you cut up no i i cut out as
well i'm not sure if it was me or
i think it oh i think you're gone again
greg um
guys can you let me know in the comments
if it's me or greg that's cut out
um because i'm not sure it's greg okay
all right
greg it's you can you can you get better
wi-fi for us
give me one sec
okay all right
let's see what we can do
all right thanks guys let's see
i think greg is changing his wi-fi all
right
you're back how are you doing
i'm not sure you guys tell me
i can hear you i can hear you yeah okay
so here my thought i apologize for this
this is the crappy canadian uh wi-fi in
an airport but uh nowhere he's gone
again
the only thing that's a hundred percent
certain in my analysis leia is that fiat
currencies will continue to debase on an
accelerated basis for that reason
you need to own protection against that
now you could argue is it an
inflationary
expectation well the truth is even in a
deflationary environment fiat currencies
will continue to debase so i don't care
whether it's inflation or deflation
it's protection against the certainty
of fiat debasement that's a very very
important context because every single
fixed income instrument in the world
is a fiat contract
so essentially you own a contract that
is guaranteed to debase in value
wow given that global debt is the
largest financial asset out there
it's a certainty that that financial
asset will continue to debase over time
it blows my mind that people haven't
done the math but clearly a lot of
people have not done the math
yeah i mean i'm not surprised because
you know people are um
you know inspired to say it not say it
say no
i don't think they're lazy
no i don't
i think the average person is inspired
and encouraged to uh talk about other
things you know like uh race and gender
and sexuality and all of the all these
all these kind of like really irrelevant
things just really distract from the
important stuff like the fact that
you're the money in your pocket is
losing value
that's the way i look at it okay that's
true because not everybody can be a
financial engineer but not everyone can
be a social scientist not everyone can
be an artist or
or whatnot but i guess at the end of the
day the biggest problem i have with this
is that all of us have children or will
likely have children
we are pulling forward gains
at the expense of our children we are
not paying our current debts
and our children will be the ones to
bear that price
and i don't feel great about that
do you have um
like a time frame for you know when you
sort of see
um actually a better question would be
we can get to a time frame a better
question be
like what kind of uh
shift do you see happening like when you
know what is bitcoin's role you know you
talk about this debt and the death
spiral like when do things change when
do we see
absolute collapse
one of the things about bitcoin
or about trading and financial markets
and we just cut out hopefully i'm back
uh one of the things you never make you
can make a price prediction but not a
time okay so over time i know what price
i believe bitcoin goes to
but i can't tell you when or it would be
foolish for me to predict an exa at an
exact time all i do know is these
10-year cycles are getting more severe
and they're getting compressed more
compressed so
i would say
knock on wood i hope i live
for the next 20 years i believe it will
be within my lifetime thank you for that
i believe it'll be within my lifetime i
have talked about a price target i have
and it's a very rational price target in
my opinion which is over two million
dollars u.s per bitcoin in today's
dollars is it 100 certainly not in the
slightest but
the market is currently pricing it at
such a low probability
that i'm now i have the correct price
target that i'm like hey
ship it in i think my odds are way
better than the odds that the market is
giving me for that potential outcome to
come true
it's interesting so these 10-year
cycles you know these different crisis
they are you said becoming worse and
closer together um so rather than
waiting for 2030 you think like 2025
there's gonna be another kind of
difficulty
going on sorry to ask um but yeah
yeah yeah you're
i yes i do i think it's a high
likelihood but i can't say for sure but
the bet the smart money would say yes
there is
okay okay and um
so
how
how does bitcoin fix that though
like from a practical standpoint
um
because
right now it's still correlated and i
know you said you know wall street or
whatever trading it like a traditional
stock and but right now it is still
correlated and it's been correlated for
a while right yeah
so when does this decoupling
research well here
i can't tell you but again it starts
with research like the research that was
done by fidelity now fidelity is a top
five global asset manager
imagine if you're the other four asset
managers that compete with fidelity
within the top five
and they offer a bitcoin silo
and the other four don't
well any large
asset allocator has relationships with
all four of those
at top oh all five of the top five it's
not hard for them to switch if they say
hey well i want to get this allocation
with fidelity and you guys aren't
aren't uh offering that
i'm gonna switch all of my assets to
fidelity and blackrock will all of a
sudden say
hold on don't go to fidelity
do it with us because we're going to
offer this silo i've seen this exist
with high yield bonds that's where i got
my uh my start in canada 20 years ago
there was zero
high-yield bond managers in canada now
their every single asset manager in
canada offers a high-yield bond silo
because it makes sense so the same thing
will happen with bitcoin
the same thing will happen with these
asset managers that are kicking and
screaming against this asset class will
have to embrace it because the clients
are demanding that they offer it
and embrace it in what way you know are
we talking you know bitcoin as the world
reserve currency we're talking about
more countries adopting it you know the
bitcoin standard like specifically what
is that adoption it'll be a process
okay so let's talk asset management that
will be
a
a diversification strategy within the
asset management silos which include
pension funds university endowments uh
mutual funds etfs etc but then if you
take it a level higher one of the
reasons they might want to get involved
is because they see countries like el
salvador doing what el salvador did and
bringing 44 other central bank
or central bankers from small countries
albeit but imagine if a country like
canada my hometown or home country
decided to price bitcoin
decided to use bitcoin to price our oil
and natural gas
whoa
well i think it makes sense as an
engineer and once that happens
the adoption continues across the world
now i'm not saying that canada is going
to do this but a smart
sovereign nation it is energy resource
rich
maybe russia for example
because they don't have a you know a
love on for the u.s petro dollar right
now can you imagine if they start
pricing their energy
in bitcoin uh-oh and then the asset
manager say damn i gotta get me some of
that because i think bitcoin as digital
energy not digital gold so that's why i
have a problem with the
inflation narrative
so much like michael saylor you know
he's a really smart engineer i'm sort of
a i'm an okay engineer but we still
understand the law of conservation of
energy and that's why i love i love the
bitcoin narrative so you see how it all
is correlated like you know you have a
country and then you have the asset
manager and then you have the individual
investor down here and it's all a
process and it's you know it's only 13
years old we got to be careful like you
know it it's it takes time for these
things to uh percolate through the
system
damn i feel like buying some bitcoin
after this conversation i mean if you're
looking at canada and canada you know
it's about canada pricing things in uh
don't don't go there though because
we're we're we have a we currently have
a ceo who's not the sharpest tool in the
shed okay so we got to be very yeah
we'll talk about that ceo in a minute um
i have some uh some questions you have a
very strong canadian accent um so i'm
yeah well we'll get into that um but
before we do actually um talk about uh
trudeau the man himself um i want to get
your take on uh what is going on bitcoin
mining right now um i personally am not
fully up to date with all of that um
i know that there's been a lot of
controversy um you tweeted i'm gonna get
it you wrote if you are a bitcoin miner
that does not control your power you are
in a [ __ ] biz
so
what does what does this mean what's the
controversy surrounding bitcoin mining
right now
i wouldn't call it a controversy by any
means i just you know i tend to look at
businesses uh as their strengths and
weaknesses and if you don't control your
input costs okay
and you don't control your output
revenue because that's set by the market
that's a very difficult business so
you're like at the funnel of input
right you have your energy input you
have your nozzle and then you have your
output which could be distribution it
could be all the things that set price
on the on the top of the funnel
you're just this function in here that
if you don't control your power
you can get squeezed from both sides and
that's exactly what's happening right
now in the bitcoin mining space so i
would argue and i'm involved in a
company in canada called validus power
where we
own our power assets we own 400
megawatts of
natural gas-fired power plants we host
some bitcoin miners there but we own the
power the miner doesn't own the power
now over time you just saw duke energy
for example a very large 50 gigawatt
company in the usa
is studying bitcoin mining and how
oh you cut out again
all right let's hope we have
hang on fluctuating
[Music]
go back a second we missed you we missed
you
it's okay duke energy go from duke
energy we missed you what happened to
them yeah
duke energy just announced that they are
uh studying bitcoin and mining bitcoin
using their
power uh assets the reason is because
the the base load of of uh of the grid
fluctuates as people turn on air
conditioners when they come home from
work then they go to sleep well the
generators keep turning if you don't
have demand for those generators you
wear out the generators and you can
collapse the grid so it's called base
load management or
base load man balancing
bitcoin mining is the perfect insert
into the base load management of any
grid
you can increase your revenues
you can turn off the miners when you
need to send the power instead of to the
miners you send it to the grid and all
of this builds a stronger infrastructure
anywhere in the world so
again the current publicly traded miners
which is the nozzle
of the funnel
they have to buy their power from the
utilities well that's not a great
business model in my opinion over time i
think that'll change
that's interesting because i mean i'm
not
super technical like that um like my
love and interest for bitcoin comes from
like a freedom standpoint um so i didn't
really know or understand the difference
between you know owning your own power
and you know what's been going on with
these companies who um are publicly
traded and people are buying their
stocks because they thought it was a
good idea and now
it's down with everything else in the
market well some of them some of them do
represent some good value right now um
having been in a distressed debt and
distressed asset trader my whole life
things are getting interesting uh in
certain companies the breakup value of
the company is higher than the implied
stock price that's when i get excited as
a restructuring guy hey hey i can i can
buy a dollar for 65 cents i i like
buying a dollar for 65 cents
yeah no i can imagine so um i wanted to
talk about canada um and i i want to
really just understand you know from
your perspective um how how the last two
years been
you know i know there's been the
lockdowns you've had medicine mandates
kind of um travel restrictions and stuff
like that um so just yeah from your from
your standpoint how's it been it's been
disappointing as a fifth year sorry a
fifth generation canadian whose uh
grandad uh fought in both world wars
incidentally year bri year uh in britain
uh my my granddad was awarded the order
of the british empire in world war one
in world war ii for bravery in fighting
for freedom
so i'm pretty uh you know it's near and
dear to my heart in the in the defense
of freedom and i think canada's uh in
the last couple of years has definitely
gone in the wrong direction this uh this
whole response to the freedom convoy in
my opinion was a spoiled little brat who
is sitting in uh in office has lived off
his daddy's credit card his whole life
and um his response is typical of a uh
you know a little bit of a
man who should not be in power
uh you know i i've said this before um i
i'm open-minded i don't believe bitcoin
should be a political tool
bitcoin is a political but as far as the
freedom goes the freedom concept that
you say you're very uh
close is near and dear to your heart i
believe the same thing and
you know i don't if you had asked me in
the in the year 2019 so three years ago
if canada ever would have frozen bank
accounts within the next 20 years so
between the year 2019 and 2039
hey foss what's your
thought that canada would would uh
freeze bank accounts i would say ah
maybe 20
and guess what three years later it's a
hundred percent certain that they would
do it
this is dangerous this is not what my
granddad fought for okay this is not
about you know this is a scared young
very weak
ceo
in power doing
uh you know very child childish things
in my opinion
you say ceo as if um he's a independent
weak scared actor you don't think he's
getting uh
getting taking orders from somewhere
closer in europe i i i know that
narrative and i don't really want to go
there but yes there's that possibility
isn't there um you know uh it certainly
seems like you can you can connect the
dots pretty easily but you know i got to
be careful here look i i have a lot of
canadian friends who you know we try and
keep politics out of this i'll just say
again a fifth generation canadian who uh
you know who's literally whose my
ancestors came to canada before the us
declared independence okay just to give
you an idea of the history that it's
there and it's it's disappointing to see
this happen because you know like
freedom is our
is what keeps
people doing good stuff in my opinion so
i i like to fight for the same things
that you like to fight for
and what's the narrative on the ground
are people happy with him um do people
feel similar to you
you know i mean the the unfortunate
circumstances is he uh he won
re-election with the minority government
again uh with less than 30 percent of
the popular vote uh but then he combined
with another uh another political party
it's sort of you know the canadian
parliamentary system is based on britain
on the uk right there's a lot of flaws
in that and uh nonetheless uh you know
we have to deal with our own uh within
the constraints of our own political
party so no the you know six seventy
percent of the population did not vote
for him as one way of looking at it uh
but that being said he's a minority
government for at least three more years
and how do you uh how do you feel about
canada in general like do you want to
stay do you feel
um you know concerned that this could
happen again you know we spoke about
these 10-year cycles but looks like it
could be a five-year cycle these days um
yeah like
what are your what are you probably
prepping
yeah i i absolutely want to stay look i
have three kids who were born here uh
they're not gonna leave in the short
term
uh
again five generations of uh you know
working to build a great country um i'd
like to think i'm not gonna cut bait and
run um
you know i i do get over my skis
sometimes uh you know that whole tracker
convoy thing was a little pressure
packed for uh for my uh my family um but
that being said you gotta stand up for
what you believe and uh this is a case
of uh i believe a concentration of power
that's dangerous that's happening
globally too though late right it's not
it's not happening just in canada so
agreed
yeah
yeah it is happening globally um it's
those g7 countries as you mentioned um
and uh
yeah i was talking to somebody today and
they asked me you know what do you think
about the future of bitcoin in terms of
you know it being banned and
things like that and i said you know not
the whole world is on the same page
i mean you just know that from the
reaction over the last two years it's
it's you know the people that ask about
it being banned or the people that you
know that love government almost they
love this they they're too weak to stand
up for their own uh rights they want
government to protect them uh in fact
it's not those people that make
countries great okay what makes
countries great in the case of usa and
uk and canada
are the people that you know that fight
for the
fight against what's wrong and um you
know i again i don't like to bring up
the the the past but my granddad was a
very highly decorated uh
uh
veteran of both world wars uh
you know he i still hear his voice in my
head sometimes like hey kid yeah like
this is not the right way for things to
go down and um
i see some of that within the bitcoin
community but look what i need to say
about the bitcoin community and having
met you in
miami very briefly but what i love about
the bitcoin community is they tend to be
a community of givers not takers okay
everyone says oh they're in it in a get
rich quick squeeze it this is the
furthest thing from a get rich quick
scheme that i've ever seen you have guys
like jeff booth one of the foremost
thinkers a personal friend of mine we
just came back from madeira uh a a trip
to madeira visiting you know the island
and the president and whatnot this is a
community of thinkers that can change
the world
and you know yourself and young women
all over the world that are getting
involved in this i i was in
the city of vancouver last night with a
bitcoin meetup in vancouver 200 people
just came out you know to to hear me you
know espouse on my opinions on things
i all i know again is i've made 35 years
of mistakes
but i believe
very confidently that bitcoin is the
best
asymmetric trade opportunity i have ever
seen in 35 years and when i say i bring
35 years of mistakes i manage those
mistakes i don't i'm not like peter
schiff i don't say oh bitcoin at ten
dollars it's a horrible deal don't ever
buy bitcoin and then it goes to seventy
thousand and comes back to twenty
thousand he's like see i told you
bitcoin was a horrible deal what a loser
okay i have to say that time and time
again the man is a horrible risk manager
and the fact that he continues to beat
up on an asset that's superior to his
love of gold is a mark of a man who is
old and curmudgeonly and i don't want to
be that person as the information
changes i will change my investment
policy so once again manage your losers
you sell your losers and you keep your
winners everybody else tends to do the
reverse
learn to manage risk people if you own
zero bitcoin you are taking far more
risk than if you own
i'm gonna throw out zero to five percent
so own five percent of bitcoin and then
don't focus on the price of bitcoin
every day you still have 95 of your
portfolio and other stuff
that is more risky than the insurance
policy that's bitcoin it's very hard to
get that through people's heads okay
they are human by nature they focus on
their
winners okay and they sell their winners
rather than doing the opposite
sell your losers things like global
bonds when global bonds were negative
yielding in europe that's not an asset
anymore that's a liability yet people
still put their money in assets
that provided a negative return what
kind of foolish behavior is that
god knows these are a bunch of sheep
running over the cliff all at the same
time yeah no it's said really perfectly
um i i saw a quote the other day which
was don't bother waking up the sheep
wake up the sleeping lions and i i like
that a lot yeah yeah i like that i don't
agree with that and and you know
you've interviewed you know the the the
likes of michael saylor and perhaps
you've interviewed some people that are
bitcoin haters the the beautiful thing
about bitcoin is
it's an education process i like to say
it's an iq test in risk management
okay it's an iq test in risk management
and there's a lot of low iq risk
managers out there okay having lived in
the pits for 35 years trust me
there is a lot of stupid low iq money
out there in the world
absolutely um greg you put that so
eloquently um so i want to thank you so
much for coming on um where can people
follow you and follow your work
i think
greg has frozen again at that very last
second
let's wait till he comes out there we go
i got you okay sorry sorry i got you no
you're okay um i was just thanking you
for uh putting that so eloquently um and
so simply and for those you know who are
still trying to learn and understand
um where can people follow you and you
know find out more about your work stay
up to date with everything that you're
doing you know if you're doing meetups
whatever it is
i'm uh you know pretty old here so i
only have one social platform it's
basically twitter uh you can follow me
on uh at foss greg foss so fos
[Music]
oh
we're we're we're gone again
all right let's see let's see if we can
get greg back
let's have a look at that f-o-s-s
we hear it now we hear it now f-o-s-s
g-r-e-g-f-o-s-s is my twitter there we
go
and again all i know all i know is see
this iphone there's more power in this
iphone than put two men on the moon when
i was alive in 1969
that technology itself
allows you to hold the banking in your
hand
it will change the world don't overthink
this
it is the most beautiful financial
technology that i have ever seen
please
respect that if you
don't listen to people with experience
in the pits you are bound to recreate
their errors like
work be smart i'll talk to you guys in
20 years okay i look forward to uh the
next time we can talk
perfect greg thank you so much i'm gonna
let you catch your flight i appreciate
you coming on and also thank you to
everyone for watching um please don't
forget to hit the subscribe button so
you don't miss a video hit the like
button and so we can continue providing
such amazing content and also a massive
thank you to bit max because of course
without them we wouldn't be able to
bring you such good content all right
we'll see you all next week bye bye
today ohio plan show